Speaker 1: And believe it or not,
that is actually the message that
presidential candidate Nikki Haley is also
trying to convey to wealthy Republican donors.
It was revealed this week that Nikki
Haley, the former ambassador to the U.N.,
former governor of South Carolina, current
presidential candidate. Sent a memo to wealthy
Republican donors basically begging them for money
by trashing. Both Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump.
Here's some of what the memo says. Here's what
the memo says about Trump. It's increasingly
clear that Trump's candidacy is more consumed
by the grievances of the past and the promise
of more drama in the future rather than a
forward looking vision for the American people.
No argument there. Like Nikki Haley, your
campaign, you hit the nail on the head.
No critiques. Beautifully executed. Her attack on
Ron DeSantis. Ron DeSantis essentially launched
his presidential campaign with a national book
tour during this period and made one misstep
after another, confirming what many observers
have long suspected. He's not ready for prime.
Again, no notes. Perfect. I agree with every word
that you said there, especially because the not
ready for prime time thing is something I
have been saying for the last two years.
Then it gets even funnier. Then she goes. And
then there are the others. Wait. What others?
They. That's it. That's how it ends. So it's
beautifully executed again. Nikki Haley, top marks
for this memo. Not that I support your candidacy,
but I got to say. You said all the right things,
because here's what's happening. As I said, this
is a memo that she sent to wealthy Republican
donors. Trump is too much drama and too much
baggage. He's in it for himself. Get rid of him.
Ron DeSantis, He's a blithering idiot that
is absolutely bumbling on the national stage.
He's got no chance. Oh, there are some other
people, maybe. But who are they? You don't
know them? I don't know them. So give me
your money. And by the way, Nikki Haley,
in the first six weeks of her campaign, raised
$11 million. Donald Trump only pulled in,
I think like somewhere between six and 9
million in the first quarter of this year. Now,
that doesn't include the massive fundraising
haul that he has had since the indictment.
But had it not been for the indictment
where Trump, according to his campaign,
raised like $10 million in two weeks, Nikki Haley
would be outraising Donald Trump right now. So
Nikki Haley is not a candidate to just laugh off
as another has been. She's actually doing well.
Not in the poll, you know, not where it
matters, but in the fundraising arena,
she's doing pretty well. You know, she's got name
recognition. She's traveling. It's been back to
Iowa a couple of times. She's going out there.
She's doing speeches, something that Trump is not.
Probably because he's got to worry
about all of his legal problems.
But Nikki Haley right now, in terms of being a
candidate again, please don't take this as I'm
saying. I support her or I like anything she
stands for. But if we take off our Partizan
Blinders and just analyze the campaign itself,
she's doing everything right. So this letter
attacking her opponents to the donors. That's a
smart move. Pointing out that she basically raised
more money than Trump is a smart move. She even
said at one point, like Donald Trump had a pretty
good first quarter, if you count being indicted as
good. So she's going no holds barred. Right. She
is, Absolutely. Let's take on Donald Trump. Let
me bloody him up. Let me show these donors that
I am the drama free path forward. I am not out
there like Ron DeSantis looking like an idiot.
I'm the real deal. That is how she's pitching
herself. And again, based on her pitch,
based on the money that she's raising, it's pretty
obvious that she is doing a decent job with this.